În acest capitol vom oferi cadrul
de gândire despre mediile de calcul
care poate fi aplicat atât pe laptopul tău
cât și scalat până la supercalculatoare
până la sfârșitul acestui capitol
vei înțelege conceptul fundamental al resurselor de calcul
și cum se relaționează între ele
deci ce sunt resursele de calcul, pur și simplu
sunt componentele care alcătuiesc un sistem de calcul
vom avea CPU-ul sau unitatea centrală de procesare
care execută cele mai multe instrucțiuni, vom avea memoria
sau RAM-ul care stochează temporar datele
și instrucțiunile de program
și avem GPU-uri sau unități de procesare grafică
care sunt proiectate pentru randare grafică
dar pot fi folosite și pentru sarcini de calcul de uz general
care necesită multă procesare paralelă
cum ar fi simulări științifice, analiză de date sau machine learning
aceste resurse lucrează împreună pentru a executa programe
și fiecare are propria sa unitate de măsură
de exemplu unitățile CPU se măsoară în nuclee
și viteză de ceas, în timp ce memoria se măsoară în bytes
în giga, mega și terabytes
pentru fiecare dintre problemele noastre
vom avea nevoie de un set de resurse
pentru a le executa
este crucial să luăm în considerare resursele necesare pentru a le executa
eficient — locul unde componentele programului sunt executate
și lățimea de bandă a infrastructurii care le conectează
joacă un rol semnificativ
în determinarea performanței generale
de exemplu, un GPU ar putea fi rapid pentru a calcula anumite părți
ale programului nostru, dar dacă încărcarea programului în memoria GPU
durează mai mult decât am economisi
ar putea fi mai rapid să folosim CPU-ul în schimb — acum
să vorbim despre scalarea resurselor clasice
avem două abordări: scalare verticală
și scalare orizontală — scalarea verticală implică creșterea
puterii unei singure resurse
cum ar fi folosirea unui CPU mai puternic sau a mai multă memorie
în cadrul unui singur nod fizic
unde nodul este o unitate a unui cluster de calcul care înglobează mai multe
resurse în interior — scalarea orizontală
implică adăugarea mai multor resurse
cum ar fi multiple CPU-uri sau GPU-uri
care să lucreze împreună pe un singur nod sau mai multe noduri
ambele abordări au propriile lor avantaje
și dezavantaje, iar alegerea depinde de cazul specific de utilizare
și cerințe — să introducem un nou tip de resursă:
resurse cuantice — resursele cuantice procesează informații cuantice
cu o unitate de procesare cuantică sau QPU — un QPU
este întregul sistem responsabil
pentru acceptarea unui set de instrucțiuni cuantice executabile
sau quantum circuit și returnarea
unui răspuns corect — asta înseamnă
că QPU-ul include unul sau mai multe chipuri cuantice
de exemplu un procesor IBM Quantum
precum și multiple componente suplimentare
într-un frigider cu diluție
care răcește chipul cuantic
cum ar fi amplificatoare cuantice, electronică de control
și calculatorul clasic necesar
pentru sarcini precum stocarea instrucțiunilor
și formelor de undă în memorie, acumularea rezultatelor
și decodarea viitoare a corecției erorilor
în general, resursele cuantice sunt măsurate
în termeni de calitate prin scala de fidelitate stratificată
numărul de qubiți
și viteza — operații de strat circuit pe
secundă sau CLOPS — astăzi vom trata chipul cuantic
ca unitate de măsură, similar cu modul în care sistemele de gestionare a resurselor
tratează GPU-urile — nu prin numărul de nuclee
ci prin întreaga unitate — dar ce e cu scalarea?
la fel ca resursele clasice, scalarea resurselor cuantice poate
fi de asemenea categorizată în verticală
și orizontală — scalarea verticală
ar fi creșterea numărului de qubiți per chiplet
sau per chip
scalarea orizontală ar fi conectarea chipurilor
cu cuploare sau cu interconectări clasice
cu această definiție pusă la punct
să vorbim despre gestionarea resurselor
gestionarea resurselor în infrastructura de calcul se referă
la procesul de planificare
alocare și control al utilizării resurselor de calcul
cum ar fi CPU, memorie, stocare
și lățimea de bandă de rețea pentru a asigura
o utilizare eficientă și efectivă a resurselor
poți să te gândești la gestionarea resurselor
ca la un joc de Tetris multidimensional, unde blocurile
sunt cerințele jobului tău
iar fiecare dimensiune este o unitate de resursă — sarcina generală
este să potrivești aceste blocuri de joburi într-un cub
din toate resursele disponibile — gestionarea resurselor
este o sarcină foarte dificilă și diferite facilități de calcul implementează
tactici diferite pentru a-și configura infrastructura
pentru nevoile specifice ale bazei lor de utilizatori
pentru a aplica conceptele pe care tocmai le-am învățat, vom folosi
Slurm — Slurm este un software open source
pentru gestionarea resurselor
în scopuri de demonstrație
am o configurație locală cu trei noduri virtuale
putem obține informații despre acele resurse de calcul
rulând comanda scontrol
vom avea două partiții sau grupuri de noduri
normal și quantum — partiția normală este compusă din noduri
care au acces doar la resurse clasice
iar partiția cuantică are acces la resurse cuantice
să rulăm mai întâi simplul
exemplu clasic hello world cu Slurm
mai întâi avem nevoie de programul hello world în sine.
Și iată programul nostru care pur și simplu afișează hello
world.
Acum trebuie să-i spunem managerului de resurse
ce resurse avem nevoie pentru a executa acest program
după cum am discutat, Slurm oferă o modalitate de a specifica
toate metadatele pentru un job prin
un script shell
cu anumite adnotări specifice Slurm
aceste adnotări îți permit să specifici cerințele de resurse
parametrii de planificare și multe altele.
Putem verifica scriptul nostru de trimitere
și aici avem specificarea partiției
câte noduri avem nevoie, câte sarcini per nod vom
executa, câte CPU-uri per sarcină vom folosi
și ce script vrem să rulăm
și acesta este programul nostru hello world.
Pentru a trimite jobul spre execuție trebuie doar să rulăm
o singură comandă, care este sbatch
și să furnizăm scriptul nostru ca argument
putem verifica coada de execuție
și vedem că programul nostru hello world rulează
pe partiția normală, pe nodul c1
odată ce jobul este terminat, putem verifica rezultatele
uitându-ne la fișierul de ieșire.
Și asta e tot.
Suntem interesați și de utilizarea resurselor cuantice
de aceea să creăm un simplu program hello Qiskit.
Iată programul nostru Qiskit care are toți
pașii necesari pentru crearea unui circuit
optimizare, execuție și postprocesare.
Și iată toate conceptele de programare despre care am vorbit
quantum circuit, transpiler
și primitivele Qiskit
acum trebuie să creăm scriptul de trimitere
ca înainte, dar aici specificăm
cerințele de resurse cuantice
deoarece am specificat resursele
și partiția din cluster
ce resurse cuantice sunt disponibile
primitivele Qiskit vor folosi
resursele alocate pentru a executa circuitele cuantice.
Acum trebuie să rulăm programul nostru.
Și odată ce jobul e gata, putem verifica rezultatele.
Și iată valoarea noastră de așteptare.
Și asta e tot pentru gestionarea resurselor
în secțiunea următoare vom vorbi
despre modele de programare